it was really just a really emotional
experience they think more than I had
anticipated and even as someone who
works on the Syrian humanitarian crisis
every day I don't think I've ever been
grabbed so emotionally
if you see that how how could you not
want to do something about this you know
how could you not want to contribute or
sign the petition that's you know at the
very least or get involved with an
organization somehow volunteered for
this crisis that's happening you know it
was very heartbreaking to see but at the
same time it's necessary feels very real
and you know you get really disoriented
and you know you kind of forget your
you're just standing in DC and not
really at the camp four years ago no one
could have foreseen the tragedy Syria
would soon face Obama wants to degrade
and destroy the Islamic state and now
the United States